bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes jeudi 7
juillet vous regardez le 7 8 le journal
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition comme chaque jour nous
revenons sur votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite on commence avec le sommaire une
journaux taux de la santé c'est est
aujourd'hui à trappes l institut de
promotion de la santé organise sa
première journée portes ouvertes
ateliers démonstrations et conférences
étaient organisées l'occasion de
découvrir les services de santé proposée
par les 23 partenaires de libé s et le
club face à saint quentin en yvelines
fondation pour agir contre l'exclusion
prend une autre dimension dès la rentrée
il devient face et yvelines et étend son
action sur un plus grand territoire et
avec de nouveaux partenaires
bilan et perspectives aujourd'hui avec
notre invité moi mais de montsouris son
président et enfin la france en
demi-finale de l'euro 2016 c'est ce
jeudi soir contre l'allemagne
les bonnes performances et des bleus
booster l'économie française c'est ce
que nous verrons nous parlerons
également pronostics et un mode économie
pour commencer aujourd'hui jeudi 7
juillet gfi informatique 8e entreprises
des services du numérique français
organisé une journée portes ouvertes
recrutement à saint quentin en yvelines
une quarantaine de candidats ont été
présélectionnés pour l'événement il
était amené à rencontrer les équipes de
recrutement techniques et commerciales
30 postes sont à pourvoir d'ici la fin
2016 sur la région de france pour
renforcer les activités applications
services infrastructures et conseil du
groupe
marlène escure directrice recrutement
france chez gfi informatique nous
explique l'intérêt de ce job dating
l'idée de ce type d'événement c'est de
concentrer sur là l'après-midi en tout
cas et début de soirée des équipes à la
fois recrutement opérationnelle et
commerciale et de s'assurer qu'on puisse
attirer le candidat sur ce procès ce qui
serait raccourcie puisque il va
rencontrer
l'idée des personnes qui interviennent
dans du procédures de recrutement sur
cet événement il est temps de passer à
présent notre entretien nous accueillons
à ce soir mohamed de montsouris
directeur du club face à saint quentin
en yvelines et non pas président je me
suis trompé tout à l'heure on saura vous
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors le club place pour ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas c'est la
fondation agir contre l'exclusion
une initiative créée par treize grands
groupes français et initié par martine
aubry elle favorise l'engagement social
et sociétal des entreprises pour août
pour lutter contre toute forme
d'exclusion de discrimination et de
pauvreté par une approche globale et
innovante de responsabilité sociale
d'entreprise
alors si on rappelle brièvement vos
missions vous oeuvrez auprès des publics
comme les scolaires les seniors pour les
accompagner et favoriser leur accès à
l'emploi et vous avez fêté vos 15 ans
l'année dernière
oui tout à fait effectivement le club de
saint quentin en yvelines a été créé en
99 donc à l'initiative de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et donc qui
fait partie du réseau national est
effectivement donc on a fêté nos cases
en tout récemment et donc ça permet
effectivement de faire un bilan
au cours de ces quinze dernières années
puis surtout effectivement de préparer
la suite puisque on espère encore
continuer notre action pendant un
certain nombre d'années encore justement
la suite on veut en parler il ya de
nouvelles perspectives pour vous à
partir de septembre
vous n'allez plus être seulement le club
fasse mais le club fasse yvelines alors
est-ce qu'on puisse en dire un peu plus
oui tout à fait alors c'est en fait ça
s'inscrit dans une dynamique on impulse
sur le sur le club depuis plusieurs
années est effectivement donc comme je
disais tout à l'heure le club a été créé
à l'initiative de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et apporter
son action prioritairement sur le
territoire de saint quentin on y vit
c'est vrai que nous aujourd'hui on
souhaite aller au delà de ce territoire
là en ayant une disposition une
couverture départementale donc sur le
département des yvelines et pouvoir
effectivement dupliquer ce qu'on fait à
saint quentin en yvelines sur de
nouveaux territoires du département
alors comment cela va se passer du coup
il va y avoir d'autres personnes qui
vont rejoindre l'association sert un
partenariat qui est menée parce que ça
va être un grand oui tout à fait ça veut
dire nouveau territoire c'est-à-dire
découverte aussi de certains territoires
découvrir de nouvelles entreprises
puisque effectivement nous notre action
s'articule autour des entreprises et
puis du monde économique
donc on a effectivement déjà engagé des
actions pour fédérer des entreprises sur
ces nouveaux territoires et notamment du
côté de la vallée de seine et donc à
terme effectivement on devrait
voir proposer l'ensemble de nos actions
à la fois école et puis au niveau de
l'emploi au niveau du département alors
scellier donc à la convention vous avez
signé le 1er juillet lyon un partenariat
avec le gie oui tout à fait en fait on a
signé une convention de partenariat avec
le gir vallée de seine qui a un réseau
d'entreprise assez important puisque ce
sont 230 entreprises de la vallée de
seine qui effectivement sont présents au
sein de ce groupement d'entreprises et
donc on a présenté effectivement
d'attraction auprès de leurs entreprises
adhérentes pour favoriser l'emploi des
jeunes sur ces territoires mais aussi un
partenariat également avec activity
qu'on connaît bien ici à dans les
yvelines
oui tout à fait en fait à nice est il de
cette extension départemental c'est le
soutien d'activités kehl agence
d'insertion porté par le département et
puis la préfecture qui a souhaité en
fait nous accompagner pour développer
les actions emploi auprès des jeunes
bénéficiaires du rsa et donc en fait
cette démarche d' extension s'inscrit
dans ce cadre là alors c'est bien sûr un
lien aussi avec la fusion le futur des
yvelines alors oui et non c'est à dire
que nous effectivement on s'inscrit dans
ce plan de développement territorial en
dupliquant notre action sur d'autres
territoires sur de nouveaux territoires
et puis s'agit aussi de dupliquer le
partenariat avec nos entreprises sur ces
territoires là et puis sarthe il s'agit
surtout en fait de proposer nos actions
auprès de nos bénéficiaires et puis
effectivement à terme
hélas effectivement la configuration que
souhaite le réseau national face c'est
de pouvoir disposer de clubs à vocation
départementale
et puis c'est vrai que sur l'île de
france on a effectivement cette ce
projet de mariage entre les yvelines et
pilot de cette donc on suit ça de très
près avec notamment nos collègues de
fass paris puis de face la défense
alors est-ce que vous resterez sur les
mêmes missions on a beaucoup parlé dans
atv file associé
khademi sur à d'autres d'autres choses
qui vont aussi être que tu as plus en
lien avec france ce territoire a grandi
oui tout à fait alors l'idée c'est de
s'appuyer effectivement sur nos actions
existantes qui marche très bien cheap
job academy on a eu l'occasion de
d'avoir plusieurs reportages au niveau
de tes fils 78 on a prévu effectivement
aussi de proposer des actions types de
graines d'entreprise ou là effectivement
ça marche très bien et puis on souhaite
aussi lancer de preuves des projets
innovants notamment autour de la
découverte des métiers du numérique par
exemple on a un projet qui s'appelle
louis
qui qui devrait se mettre en place à
partir de la rentrée où là il s'agit
d'accompagner sensibiliser des filles
aux métiers du numérique on a également
reconfirmé reformater job academy pour y
intégrer des séquences plus autour du
numérique notamment avec le cv vidéo
et puis on a prévu effectivement un
projet autour de la mixité qui s'appelle
projet ses hommes alors s'il y aura plus
de personnes pour vous aider à amener
cette mission nouveaux territoires veut
dire aussi effectivement une
organisation qui s'y prêtent donc là
aujourd'hui au niveau de la structure on
est quatre salariés et donc l'objectif
c'est de pouvoir afin de couvrir sur ce
territoire là et propose effectivement
nos actions qu on l organisation qui
soit la plus adéquate possible donc en
ayant effectivement des moyens
complémentaires donc des moyens
complémentaires qui sont assurées déjà
d'une part par l' agence activity qui
seront assurées aussi on l'espère pour
la région ile de france
et puis par les entreprises partenaires
ça ne changera rien pour les personnes
dont vous occupez qui font déjà partie
de vos missions
non alors au niveau des bénéficiaires
effectivement ça n'a aucun impact
puisque l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
continuer à proposer un service de
qualité d'accompagnement auprès de nos
bénéficiaires
par contre effectivement il s'agit de
dupliquer ce qu'on fait auprès de ses
bénéficiaires là sur d'autres
territoires et créer une dynamique
autour d'un réseau d'entreprises
engagées sur les questions sociales et
sociétales
merci on revient sur cette année avec
ses clefs donc depuis la rentrée en
septembre des médias quel bilan
faites-vous c'était plutôt la bonne
année vous avez multiplié les actions
oui alors on essaie effectivement de
toujours d'être dans cette dynamique là
en terme d'action et puis de projets
innovants alors les faits marquants sur
premier semestre a été plusieurs jobs
académies notamment la clôture de la job
academy avec banque populaire val de
france qui a quand même mis à
disposition une dizaine de parrains
marraines avec des sorties en emploi
très significative
on a également effectivement le projet
du académie qui a été mise en place avec
la société kinnarps puis à côté de ça on
a aussi d'autres projets tels que peines
parcours emploi mobilité sport avec donc
la question de l'apprentissage
et puis la graine d'entreprise puisqu'on
arrive effectivement à terme de ce
projet de graines l'entreprise avec de
graines ou là on a
plusieurs jeunes qui ont été investis
sur le sur le projet et qui a permis de
vendre à peu près une centaine de
batteries solaires et puis plus de 300
supports design pour téléphones
portables les opérations qui ont le
mieux marché ces jobs diademys c'est
vraiment un partenariat ou à des
personnes qu'on accompagne vers l'emploi
par des chefs d'entreprise ou
d'établissement intérêts de l'entreprise
et oui alors c'est une action en fait
qui symbolise parfaitement l'essence
même est l'adn du club fasse
effectivement avoir un action qui soit
porté par l'entreprise et qui se traduit
par des engagements individuels des
équipes et puis des collaborateurs et
puissent accéder projet très fédérateur
et qui apporte aussi une cohésion et de
valoriser aussi ses ressources humaines
au sein même des entreprises
vous avez noël à de nouveaux
partenariats notamment avec eux les
terribles les acteurs du territoire
local
oui alors on a commencé effectivement
sur le territoire du grand paris seine
et oise avec la rencontre de plusieurs
réacteurs on est parti à la rencontre
des équipes des territoires d'action
sociale dont qui sont portées par le
département
on a rencontré plusieurs réseaux
d'entreprises donc dont le jir vallée de
seine mais on a rencontré également
d'autres réseaux type les murs
entreprise entreprise et passion
également à poissy on a rencontré aussi
des entreprises qui ont une activité sur
place et qui sont partenaires au niveau
du club saint quentin en yvelines et
donc effectivement fait un appel aussi
aux entreprises aux chefs d'entreprise
qui souhaiteraient s'investir sur ces
actions là donc implanté sur ce
territoire de grand paris seine et oise
je pense également à un nouveau
partenaire c'est un chanteur récemment
l'école d'ingénieurs estaca pour ouvrir
la prochaine
oui tout à fait alors l'estac a
effectivement on a eu un premier contact
positif avec eux et puis donc on a
décidé de de transformer ce contact là
en action et on devrait organiser
effectivement à partir du du mois
d'octobre une opération qui va permettre
en fait à des filles collégiennes et
lycéennes d'être sensibilisés d'être
accompagnés sur les métiers industriels
avec des étudiantes et puis des salariés
femmes d'entreprises partenaires
une dernière question moyennement se
voulait ce que justement voilà cette
opération pour accompagner les filles
l'acte de discrimination l'égalité
hommes-femmes ça va être aussi quelque
chose d'important l'année prochaine au
sein de fass facile dès maintenant
oui tout à fait alors c'est
effectivement une thématique qui ressort
chaque année c'est à dire que nous on
essaye de avec les entreprises
partenaires justement de proposer ce
type de type d'action d'autant plus
qu'il ya des secteurs d'activité qui
cherche à sensibiliser les filles sur
ces métiers techniques mais inversement
c'est aussi sensibiliser les garçons sur
des métiers à prédominance féminine
donc l'objectif c'est de pouvoir croiser
un petit peu ces actions-là et proposer
des actions au plus près de nos
entreprises est au plus près de nos
publics merci à beaucoup mohamed
mansouri on vous retrouvera donc en
septembre directeur cette fois de face à
yvelines non plus de fast 50 en yvelines
à merci à vous fans aussi un point
maintenant un tourisme al'approche de
l'été qu'en est il pour les hôtels de
l'agglomération sans la clientèle
d'affaires c'est parfois compliqué pour
les professionnels de maintenir leur
activité les auberges et les chaînes
n'ont pas la même clientèle
mais rencontre parfois des difficultés
exemple à l'auberge du manet et au
kyriad de montigny le bretonneux avec et
fanny bourdillon call of town madame
isabelle welcome to des auberges de
manette
massicot et isabelle dans cette auberge
de luxe de montigny le bretonneux les
clients étrangers sont choyés cette
année ils se sont faits plutôt rares
une déception pour cette gérante qui
pensaient engendrer une hausse de son
chiffre d'affaires de 30% avec l'effet
euro 2016 du mois de juin sur l'euro
on a absolument aucun on a eu très très
peu de réservations par rapport à ça
très très peu du fait que vous auriez eu
les attentats du fait eu les grèves du
fait que au niveau image internationale
on a quand même beaucoup souffert
et puis les étrangers ont eu peur je
veux dire non forcément ça impacte et
paris et du coup ça nous a un paquet
parce que
logiquement contrat quand de paris
travaille très très bien au niveau
touristique nous on a toujours des
retombées
isabelle fait désormais appel à des
tours opérateurs et pour attirer une
clientèle étrangère et familiale
l'accent est mis sur une cuisine
française de qualité pour les étrangers
généralement c'est important pour eux
ils aiment bien avoir plusieurs desserts
compter que ça soit frais et un peu
exotique à quelques kilomètres l'enjeu
est totalement différent pour cet hôtel
implanté au milieu d'une zone
d'activités la proximité de grandes
sociétés leur permet d'être souvent
complet du dimanche au jeudi soir la
semaine effectivement né clientèle 100%
d'affaires et comment ça se passe alors
les week-ends alors les week-ends c'est
très calme
on essaie d'attirer une clientèle de
loisirs on a un petit peu de mal on
avait une clientèle étrangère qui venait
dans notre établissement
les week-ends mais suite aux attentats
qui a eu elle ne vient plus avec
l'arrivée des vacances scolaires
l'activité hôtelière diminue fortement
dans l'agglomération pour rester
attractif cet hôtel propose des
promotions sur les chambres allant
jusqu'à 50%
en attendant une reprise de l'activité à
la rentrée et cette information que nous
avons eue aujourd'hui l'association à
greenpeace france a déposé plainte ce
jeudi contre la société gestionnaire de
l'hypermarché edouard leclerc de bois
d'arcy dans les yvelines pour mise en
danger délibérée de la vie d'autrui et
violences volontaires
les faits remontent au 22 juin dernier
lors d'une action non violente visant à
dénoncer la présence de pesticides dont
les fruits et légumes vendus par
l'enseigné ce jour là une quarantaine de
militants de greenpeace avaient
greenpeace avaient fait irruption dans
le magasin et déployer deux banderoles
les militants à dénoncent la réaction
musclée des vigiles et de certains
salariés de leclerc contacté par nos
soins l'enseigné leclerc n'a pas
souhaité faire de commentaire et on
prend à présent la direction et de
trappes une grande journée était
organisée autour de la santé l'institut
de promotion de la santé organisé sa
première journée portes ouvertes
l'occasion de découvrir les services de
santé proposée par les 23 partenaires de
lits ps williams elle pour ce reportage
ça sert à rien ne faites pas ça faut pas
le faire non plus tu vas bien et les
gens s'ils attrapent la prévention
devient attrayante pour sa première
journée portes ouvertes l'institut de
promotion de la santé organise des
conférences ateliers et démonstrations
une manière plus attractive d'attirer le
public selon la directrice
on s'est rendu compte par nos études en
fait que quand on découvrait un lieu une
première fois surtout un lieu de santé
sans avoir une problématique en fait on
y vient beaucoup plus facilement par la
suite c'est pas très facile en fait
d'accéder de parler de santé de manière
générale donc on a voulu mettre en forme
en place différentes formes d'ateliers
donc il y à des mini conférences par
exemple une mini conférence sur
l'estiment de soi donc à chaque fois ce
sont nos partenaires qui les anime ça
permet de leur donner la visibilité avec
ses 23 partenaires glee ps accueille
environ 13000 personnes par an
aujourd'hui c'était l'occasion de
découvrir la structure pour les
habitants mais aussi pour les
professionnels c'est quand on y pense
pas souvent à faire un partenariat avec
mais ça qu'il ya beaucoup de choses de
sensibilisation qu'ils font et c'est
vraiment très intéressant et justement
on est là pour essayer de voir qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire de plus en deux
avec en fait dans au sein de notre
hôpital et pour faire de la prévention
au niveau de nos patients le site ouvert
toute l'année accueille la population de
manière totalement anonyme pour une
écoute un bilan de santé ou une
vaccination
un seul objectif pour la structure
promouvoir l'accès à la santé pour tous
et culture à présent le travail du
photographe laurent moreau est exposé à
la galerie d'art ici et ailleurs à
versailles depuis le 21 juin
l'artiste propose de s'immiscer dans le
monde animalier avec son exposition
émotions animal habitué aux paysages
colorés
il s'est concentré sur un style
spécifique le sépia comme vous font
découvrir à manon labat et william elle
a l'air émerveillé presque aillerie
c'est à se demander ce que regarder
cette lionne pour avoir ce regard si
particulier
laurent moreau présente son exposition
émotions animal à la galerie d'art ici
et ailleurs à versailles ce choix
diffèrent de son travail habituel le
globe trotter est coutumier des modèles
humains et des couleurs ici le
photographe n'a fait ces photos quand
c'est bien c'est vraiment un choix
artistique et le rapprochement et de
dégager une certaine émotion dans ces
cesu animaux que je que j'espère presque
humain
l'artiste s'est décrit comme un passeur
d'émotions il a figé ces regards grâce à
un téléobjectif très puissant en se
rapprochant au maximum des bêtes pour
cette exposition la fête une série tout
à fait particulière qui a été initié à
pompe
après un premier voyage au botswana où
j'ai voulu prendre des photos un petit
peu particulière des animaux avec des
émotions beaucoup plus vous voyez par
exemple ici on est on est des portraits
très très très rapprochée de de lyon de
l'yonne
voilà donc j'ai ce que j'ai voulu c'est
vraiment redonné une une façon de voir
un petit peu différente pour les animaux
en mémoire de son grand-père l'artiste
s'est tourné vers le sépia un hommage
que le rembourse partagera dans la
galerie d'art tout l'été jusqu'au 30
septembre
et vous l'avez vu et constaté l'été est
enfin là c'est le moment de profiter des
activités à 2 plein air à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
on a inauguré aujourd'hui un nouvel
espace événementiel le village sportif
installé dans l'espace de l'ancienne
piscine à vagues
il a ouvert ses portes pour accueillir
des jeunes du centre de loisirs de 11 à
17 ans et propose de nombreuses
activités avec de nouveaux équipements
il est ouvert jusqu'au 9 août 9 août les
précisions recueillies par intrigue red
bull x fighters une multitude
d'activités donc qui sont soit en
activité libre on fait du prêt de
matériel ou soit des activités encadrées
avec donc des
diplômé d'état notamment sur différentes
activités telles que du flag rugby du
sport de plage du centre bal du
badminton
on a des nouveautés comme l'archerie tag
qui est une activité avec des arcs
notamment on a plutôt pas mal de monde
effectivement les créneaux sont déjà
bien préremplie
actuellement pratiquement l'ensemble des
journées sont couvertes à hauteur de 80%
en termes de créneaux et nous ouvrons
une page sports à présent nous recevons
sur notre patton trojan est sportif est
muté à demi d'euros pour la dernière
chronique sport de la saison mickaël
bonsoir à vous ça floral je suis très
heureux de partager ce moment avec vous
pour cette dernière c'est un peu triste
mais c'est un petit peu triste
il faut viser une dernière voilà
exactement pour cette chronique vous
avez vous parlé du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je ne peux
rien vous cacher floral l'open de france
de golf s'est terminée dimanche dernier
par la victoire surprise du thaïlandais
jay dee paix rassurez vous si vous êtes
un amateur de golf et de la petite balle
blanche
d'autres compétitions seront organisées
dans le lait à prochains mois sur les
greens de l'albatros le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisera
notamment un tournoi majeur du 8 au 11
septembre l'événement baptisé paris les
djeuns championship ce accueillera des
golfeurs de l'european senior tour des
joueurs de plus de 50 ans florane ce
sera une grande première pour le golf
saint quentinois elle remplacera le
french riviera master s'organiser
pendant dix ans à terre blanche en
provence on écoute l'organisateur à
pierre-antoine me sud
la volonté c'est de ces de réunir les
des joueurs de légende ce tournoi on
voulait pas l'appeler open de france
seniors on a décidé de l'appeler le
parise les jeunes tient peu cheap et on
a dès la première édition
un très beau plateau de joueurs est ce
qu'il y aura des stars du golf sur le
green de l'albatros amical 40 les gens
du golfe vont s'affronter sur les trois
jours de compétition parmi eux
l'américain john delli vainqueur de
l'open britannique en 1995 et de lui s
pizza en 91
le gall les gallois à ian whitman quatre
fois vainqueur de la ryder cup
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde du
golf et l'écossais colin montgomerie qui
a glané la razer à cinq reprises pour
accueillir ce plateau d'exception les
organisateurs voulaient absolument créer
un événement au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le parcours de l'albatros avec la bon là
on a on a actuellement l'open de france
c'est ça devient un parcours de légende
il va devenir un parcours mythique avec
la ryder cup en 2018 pour la première
fois en france donc voilà donc c'est le
choix ça s'imposait pour que on le fasse
ici et la fédération française de golf
nous aide énormément le toutes les
structures du golf national vont être à
notre disposition pendant une semaine
est-ce que vous pensez que ce tournoi va
s'implanter sur le retirer le territoire
50 inhabitée alors je pense que oui
floral la fédération française du golfe
et les organisateurs du tournoi veulent
créer un événement annuel à l'image de
l'open de france de golf sur les greens
de l'albatros on écoute
l'organisateur on a signé sur trois ans
et la volonté de ce tournoi c'est de
monter en puissance de faire venir de
plus en plus de joueurs de renom de
légende de d'augmenter le prize money et
à terme c'est d'organiser le premier
wgc donc world golf championship donc à
premiers championnats du monde seniors
sur le sol français grâce qui n'a jamais
été fait ce qui se fait sur sur les
autres catégories de deux professionnels
si vous voulez observé à ses joueurs de
légende l'événement est gratuit je vous
le rappelle les dates le pari les jeunes
championship organisé du 8 au 11
septembre golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'oubliera pas
ce rendez vous via la passe est un peu
lent mais je vais noté dans mon agenda
comme chaque rang de conseiller à la fin
de l'émission on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants pour votre toile
question par ea sports la dernière
également de la saison dernière de la
saison ce trafic nous allons justement
parlé du golfe et de la victoire de
jay-z ou à l'open de france de golf ne
font également un bilan de la saison des
sportifs et des clubs avec les tops et
les flops de chaque club
et si vous êtes un fan de sport il nous
faut absolument pas rater ce rendez vous
jusqu'à couleurs après je serai là bien
sûr merci beaucoup michael reste avec
nous on parle de foot avec bien sûr
l'euro 2016 une étude demandée par
l'uefa vont le début de la compétition
évaluer les retombées économiques de
l'euro 2016 à 2,8 milliards d'euros la
compétition n'est pas encore terminée
vous savez bien mais les commerçants
ressentent déjà les effets augmentation
des ventes ou fréquentation plus
importante des terrasses les commerces
saint quentinois sont également
concernés regardez ce reportage signé
nicolas d'andré maillot de l'équipe de
france ballon mais aussi produits
dérivés les supporters se les arrachent
dans cette enseigne d'articles de sport
les ventes connaissent une progression
beaucoup plus forte que lors de la coupe
du monde de 2014
le fait que l'euro se passe sur le sol
national et vince a permis de faire
décoller les ventes
on fait de très forte progression et le
mois de juin on peut voir une
progression d'à peu près 50% du chiffre
d'affaires sur le marché des sports
collectifs
nous avons paillettes et griezmann qui
sont très demandés forcément puisque et
griezmann
il me semble a été l'un des meilleurs
buteurs de la compétition
et voilà sont essentiellement c'est de
ces deux joueurs
ce commerce soit aussi une émulation
autour du football avec l'achat de
produits pour des activités extra
scolaires d'ici la fin de la compétition
il vise une augmentation de 80% du
chiffre d'affaires
une effervescence qui touche également
le secteur de la restauration
habituellement c'est plutôt avec le avec
le avec le flux est donc et le passage
donc on fait y apprend et on a une
dizaine de réservations et on fait un
peu près 50 couverts mais donc là c'est
vraiment les réservations posés pour que
les gens soient devant la télé on l'a
déjà vécu en 2014 avec la coupe du monde
du brésil où il y avait pas mal de monde
devant cette enseigne ini monteyne voit
une progression de 30% lors d'un match
de l'équipe de france elle enregistré
plus de 60 des réservations pour le
match france allemagne et vous savez
bien sûr ce soir la france affronte
l'allemagne en demi finale un match que
vous n'avez certainement pas rater le
jour descoings est arrivé c'est un match
bien sûr serré avec elle la meilleure
attaque qui affronte la meilleure
défense
aaron le warrant le successeur de paul
le poulpe au zoo de thoiry a donné son
pronostic
après un début de tour un moyen il avait
juste pour le 8e de finale contre
l'irlande et le quart de finale le quart
de finale face à l'islande vous voyez
sur les images c'est malheureusement la
mancha qu'ils donnent gagnante mais bon
on n'oublie pas qu'il s'est quand même
déjà trompé sien est en tout cas chacun
a ses pronostics sur ce match et a
terrific ce sont 18 est également lié à
les patriotes les pessimistes les
historiens du football regardez les
pronostics de la rédaction
3 2 pour la france 3 2 pour la france 2
1 pour l'allemagne 1-0 allemagne la
première mi temps 1 1 à la fin des temps
réglementaire
tirs au but 6-5 pour la france c'est
très serré du frisson de langouët 3 pour
l'allemagne
ça fait soixante ans comme a perdu
contre l'allemagne donc on va perdre
encore une fois 1 0 pour la france
reset ramat cher et vous que c'est une
demi finale l'allemagne se défend donc
savez cette série je dirais devin pour
la france aller j'irai 3 pour la france
alors je pense que la france va gagner 2
à 1 au stade vélodrome
un vélodrome chaud bouillant c'est sûr
et certain la france va gagner en plus
et allemands n'ont pas eu de réponse à
demain on va voir qui s'est trompé qui a
eu raison
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis demain
vous retrouvez votre journal de fin de
semaine présenté par wilfrid est riche y
ait ce sera sephora namani qui vous
donnera vos idées de sorties dans les
sept huit week-ends quand à moi je vous
retrouve lundi pour une nouvelle édition
du journal je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée et un très bon week
end